bonsoir nous sommes le 22 avril 2015 il
est l'heure du journal de la rédaction
comme chaque jour du lundi au vendredi
et dans l'actualité yvelinoise à bois
d'arcy les berges du canal paysager de
la croix bonnets sont régulièrement
inondée en cas de fortes pluies
l'accès au ponton a même été interdit
récemment le concours ma thèse en 180
secondes permettent aux doctorants de
présenter leurs sujets de recherche en
français et en termes simples un
auditoire profane et diversifiée
lauréate sur le secteur paris saclay
elle aura la n 6 n'a pas participé à la
finale nationale le 3 juin annonce il
est l'invité de cette édition et puis le
haras des bréviaires vient de présenter
aujourd'hui son nouveau spectacle
prouesses équestres et humour pour
morgane lives et artistes en résidence
ou encore émotions avec une toute
nouvelle artiste diane frémion depuis le
12 mars les salariés syndiqués du groupe
snecma lutte contre ce qu'ils estiment
la politique d'austérité de leur groupe
mais durant les négociations de ces
dernières semaines en des salariés de
l'entreprise aurais tu un comportement
agressif à l'encontre de sa direction
qui elle aurait valu une mise à pied une
sanction contestée par ses collègues cgt
cfdt qui se sont rassemblés à magny les
hameaux aujourd'hui pour le soutenir on
voit très bien être dans les entreprises
il ya dans nos nombreux groupes des
remises en cause au niveau des
conditions de travail une politique
salariale qui est loin des attentes et
des réalité de ce que vivent les
salariés au quotidien dans l'envié sur
le lieu de travail en termes de
propositions salariales on considère
qu'ils auraient besoin immédiatement
d'augmenter les pensions de retraite et
les salaires de 10% pour amener un
salaire minimum à 1700 euros qui
permettra à chaque salarié de pauvres
vivent dignement et faire vivre sa
famille des lyonnais ont considéré
aujourd'hui y compris que la question du
temps de travail il doit être posée de
partout et la revendication que porte la
cgt d'aller à une semaine de 32 heures
nous par une revendication juste on
considère que ton travail emploi et
question salariale le tout le tout allié
pour vraiment porter les revendications
qu'ils puissent être prises en compte
par le patronat et par le gouvernement
malheureusement aujourd'hui on
on n'est pas trop entendu après une
rencontre avec les responsables
syndicaux et la direction la sanction à
l'encontre du salarié sera en tout cas
annulé le salarié qui va donc pouvoir
reprendre le travail autre mobilisation
celle des salariés de la société s gia
plaisir lancé le 16 avril dernier et qui
touche à sa fin dans cette entreprise du
secteur de l'aéronautique ils sont une
centaine à souhaiter une hausse de
salaire de 70 euros bruts alors que la
direction proposait jusqu'à présent 35
en expliquant devoir contenir ses prix
pour ses clients et pendant ce temps aux
états unis vous avez sans doute entendu
parler de dan trahi ce chef d'entreprise
qui a décidé de baisser son salaire
annuel d'un million à 70 milles dollars
afin d'augmenter ses 120 salariés c'est
une décision qui a été prise en plein
débat de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
sur les inégalités salariales qu'en
pensez-vous c'est notre question du jour
révisons j'ai jamais vu ça
que du bien que des biens ou de point de
la situation de l'entreprise
forcément s'il n'y a pas d'évolution de
salaire de plan promo ou dans une
entreprise c'est bien que le patron
fasse un effort aussi pourvu que ça
continue sur cette voie là c'est parfait
je prouve que ça continue sur cette voie
là on va pas chez nous pourquoi ça se
passe hors d'allemagne c'est bien
dommage on n'entendait pas nous des
patrons vion vesa encore mais ça va
venir vite être un jour l'espoir pomare
v bah je sais pas trop parce qu'en fait
ça va dépendre aussi des actionnaires ou
pas et que s'il ya des actionnaires le
patron et je sais pas s'il a trop de
possibilités de choix par contre je
pense qu'il serait possible en france ça
tient que du défunt c'est que de la
volonté en fait
on change de sujet à présent à bois
d'arcy le canal paysager du quartier de
la croix bonnet connaît quelques
dysfonctionnements ce lieu de promenade
qui est très prisé par les habitants
seraient régulièrement inondée lors de
fortes pluies des inondations et qui
serait dû aux nombreuses constructions
en béton qui sont apparues récemment aux
abords de ce bassin les précisions les
explications avec william l
alors l'eau actuellement et ton bon
niveau sur le canal comment vous pouvez
savoir si l'eau est au bon niveau sur le
canal de la croix bonnet
vous regardez la passerelle et quand
vous regardez vous voyez les v en
dessous quand vous voyez le niveau d'eau
en dessous des v ça veut dire que l'eau
est au bon niveau si jérémy de bassiès
inquiète autant du niveau de l'étang de
bois d'arcy c'est que dernièrement il a
subi quelques dysfonctionnements la
balade de la croix boon est pourtant un
des lieux de promenades préférées des
artisiens serait sujet à des inondations
dans le cas de fortes pluies en fait
c'est une question de rapidité de l'eau
sur du béton l'eau coule très rapidement
donc alimente le canal rapidement et
donc vous avez une en peu de temps forts
une forte averse donc de loki qui
remplit canal c'est à cause des
constructions mais des constructions à
et du béton au fait de la construction
du pavillon avec jardin
avec des systèmes de récupération des
eaux de pluie etc lomé plus de temps
à s'écouler et comme elle met plus de
temps à s'écouler le canal haletant de
s'évacuer et les pontons ne seront pas
inonder les pontons sont la première
partie inondable de la promenade en cas
de très fortes pluies l'eau peut monter
jusqu'aux marches situé plus haut pour
le moment la promenade est interdite dès
qu'un risque est constatée même si la
municipalité réfléchit à différentes
solutions aujourd'hui on en phase
d'étude
on en phase d'étude on regarde avec des
cabinets pour connaître les volumes
d'eau qui sont ramenés dans dans le
canal
en cas de fortes précipitations
une autre solution reste possible
réhausser le niveau de la promenade et
des passerelles une solution bien trop
coûteuse pour le moment les arcisien
peuvent profiter des beaux jours pour
jouir de la promenade
le cnrs et la cpu la conférence des
présidents d'université organise chaque
année un concours intitulé ma thèse en
180 secondes chaque doctorants inscrits
doit y présenter son sujet de recherche
en français en termes simples nous avons
suivi l étape locale de ce rendez-vous
qui concernaient uniquement l'université
paris saclay le reportage de yolaine
thorez et d'élodie mois
quelques mois son entourage d sourire un
peu crispé puis quelques minutes de
concentration lors à la hune sina
doctorante à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à s'apprête à
passer sur scène elle fait partie des 12
finalistes de paris saclay pour le
concours ma thèse en 180 secondes
les doctorants doivent présenter leurs
travaux de recherche en trois minutes
chrono et à l'aide d'une seule
diapositives le jury est composé de
journalistes de professionnels de la
communication d'économie et bien sûr de
chercheurs sont jugés sur trois critères
sur leur leur aptitude à lever de gary
zeller sujet sur leur aisance en prise
de parole
et sur la clarté de leurs messages
vulgariser la science c'est quelque
chose que ont fait pas dans la recherche
notre directeur de thèse ou eux-mêmes
les stagiaires c'est vraiment un
exercice que on n'a pas l'occasion de
faire dans notre métier aujourd'hui je
vais vous présenter une masse alors
matinée nîmes anciens ni mon directeur
de thèse c'est l'acronyme de me
contacter adium abcès sus laura n'en est
pas à sa première c'est la deuxième fois
qu'il participe au concours et relève le
challenge en trois minutes elle va
tenter d'expliquer son travail depuis
deux ans l'étude d'une bactérie qui
infecte les patients atteints de
mucoviscidose pour chercher à s'en
débarrasser alors voilà maintenant faire
tout juste le roi termine sur le fil du
rasoir son passage s'est bien déroulé
parmi ses proches venus la soutenir sa
directrice de thèse elle voit dans ce
concours un réel bénéfice pour sa
doctorante bien souvent bas un concours
pour être maître de conf c'est une
trentaine de minutes quand on a déjà
fait cet exercice de vulgarisation gars
est vraiment très bien parce qu'on est
face à un jury qui est assez éclectique
et je pense que c'est un bon exercice
pour son avenir pour trouver travaillent
effectivement et où un poste dans la
recherche le jury a tranché les
résultats sont enfin dévoilées au prix
du jury en fait balle et
laura dans six mois
laura est la grande gagnante de cette
finale paris saclay elle remporte son
ticket pour l'étape suivante ceci sous
le chèque encore plus stressé que pour
le passage est extrêmement quentin c'est
fou c'est une incroyable aventure et je
suis trop contente d'aller aux finales
nationales la finale nationale se
déroulera à nancy le 3 juin et la finale
internationale à paris en automne
et la lauréate laura allen sénat est en
plateau bonsoir vous êtes donc
doctorante auprès de l'ufr des sciences
de la santé simone veil à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines félicitations
déjà pour cette victoire du 16 avril
dernier douze finalistes avec un peu de
recul qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
peut-être les traits d'humour que j'ai
essayé de mettre tout ce long de mon
discours et j'ai tenu les 3 minutes pile
poil et 180 secondes nécessaires à cet
exercice finale nationale maintenant ce
sera le 3 juin à nancy déjà une
préparation est ce qu'il va falloir
adapter ce sera le même exercice
finalement ça sera exactement le même
exercice après je vais pouvoir
retravailler encore un petit peu moins
discours sur les quelques jours je vais
avoir d'ici la finale et bien sûr serait
entraînant à l'oral comme d'habitude
devant revenir sur les détails de ce
concours mais tout d'abord la prochaine
étape ans encore après le national c'est
l'international finale internationale à
paris au mois de septembre vous y pensez
un petit peu puis sow national qu'à
l'international sa 27e nationale donc
c'est déjà pas mal de candidats à battre
et après will internationale ça fait
toujours rêver pourquoi pas cette finale
donc ce sera au mois de septembre depuis
déjà un an la première étape nationale
enfin la première étape que vous avez
déjà remporté la seconde étape nationale
plus tôt ce sera au mois de juin un peu
moins de 180 secondes peut-être
maintenant pour nous résumer le la thèse
parce qu'on va pas refaire l'exercice
complet j'ai pas vous demander de nous
résumer votre travail en 180 secondes
mais peut-être un petit peu moins sur
quoi portent ce travail documents sujet
de thèse porte sur l'étude d'une
mycobactéries donkey c est une bactérie
qui infecte
soit la peau soit les poumons de
patients tels que les patients atteints
de mucoviscidose donc une bactérie très
violente qu'on cherche à se débarrasser
à trouver de nouveaux moyens pour
pour lutter contre quand cette bactérie
est donc j'étudie les macrophages qui
sont des cellules de notre système
immunitaire et je les étudie un
parallèle de la bactérie 1 semble
également pour voir trouvé des bactéries
qui ne résisterait pas assez macrophages
et mieux mieux la connaître c'est un
travail qui vous a pris combien de temps
et qui vous occupe depuis combien de
temps tout simplement alors j'ai une
bourse mini celle de 3,1 pour réaliser
tout ce travail et là ça fait un an et
demi que je suis sur le sujet est à fond
un an et demi en 180 secondes c'est quoi
le plus difficile dans l'exercice le
plus difficile c'est la vulgarisation
parce que on a tendance à employer des
mots compliqués que nous on pense que
ceux qui ne sont pas compliquées qui
sont de notre langage courant en
laboratoire et du coup vulgariser
enlever ces mots compliqués et les
remplacer c'est le travail le plus
difficile que les avantages génomique
conférer à microbes bactéries y sommes
absence us pour une existence
intercellulaire déjà rien quelle est la
thématique déjà c'est compliqué inde
approche pour les non ils disent non
initié un tel concours ça vous apporte
quoi justement ça vous permet aussi de
d'aborder différemment le travail aussi
au quotidien de vous poser de nouvelles
questions nouvelles problématiques
peut-être pas au quotidien mais au
niveau 2 notre amélioration de nos
compétences de communication
l'amélioration de notre vision goldblat
globale de notre sujet thèse du coup
parce qu'il faut le vulgariser donc il
faut l'appréhender globalement donc ça
c'est des outils je pense très utile à
développer tout le long de la thèse pour
pouvoir soutenir au bout de 3 1 et à
voir ses compétences orales et cette
vision globale de notre tête vous aviez
déjà participé l'an dernier ou entendu
dans le reportage à ce concours pour qu
est-ce qui avait pas marché la dernière
fois et pourquoi c'est ici représenté
l'année dernière j'avais je pense voulu
faire trop compliqué j'avais encore quoi
c'est simple simplifier mon discours je
n'avais pas trop me de notes d'humour
non plus pour andy que l'humour on
apprend plus quand il ya de l'humour
dans un discours on le retient mieux
donc j'en avais amis et je pense que
j'étais plus stressée c'était la
première fois que ça se passait à
l'université paris saclay on savait pas
comment elle et ça allait se passer et
tout donc cette année j'étais plus à
l'aise cette démarche pour les
chercheurs de devoir simplifier leur
travail de présenter un résumé très très
clair très facile d'approché c'est une
nouvelle façon aussi de de rapprocher
monsieur madame tout le monde de la
science une démocratisation qui se met
en place ce existait déjà à l'étranger à
ce concours pour la france et ça vient
d'arriver pour la france et c'est
exactement ça je trouve ça génial pour
le fait de les personnes non initiés qui
veulent apprendre qu'est ce qui se passe
en recherche française ou se renseigner
dans les domaines comment comment ça se
passe c'est vraiment leur donner les
outils pour qui ce pour que ça soit
accessible et compréhensible pour tout
le monde et n'importe quelle personne
qui souhaite s'intéresser et se
documenter sur le sujet je pensais c'est
un très bon moyen et pourquoi pas
susciter des vocations parmi les plus
jeunes qu'est ce qui vous a amené à
mener vers la recherche justement
exactement ma passion pour la biologie
déjà plus particulièrement la
microbiologie donc tous qui étude de
bactéries et micro-organismes et j'ai
toujours voulu travailler dans le
domaine de la santé humaine donc santé
publique donc des sujets comme ça donc
j'ai trouvé le sujet de thèse qui
rapprocher ces deux domaines et pour le
résumé chose qu'on n'a pas précisé vous
savez tout de même l'aide d'une
diapositive une seule image bon là
choisi cette image c'est compliqué parce
qu'on a l'habitude de faire non loin des
courts communication un peu plus longue
avec une vingtaine de diapositives donc
là il faut en choisir une il faut
qu'elle ait un impact visuel assez fort
pas trop complexe pour pas que les gens
se perdent dedans et oublient de vous
écouter un votre discours donc un impact
fort assez simple et qui doit être
réellement relation avec ce que vous
dites à l'instant présent vous êtes
donné des conseils entre chercheurs où
il y avait une vraie compétition
justement d'autres participants non on a
fait tous une formation d'une journée
ensemble pendant laquelle on répétait
nos discours et on se donnait des
conseils chacun les uns les autres
qu'est ce qui est à aller mieux
qu'est-ce qui les points négatifs les
points positifs dans nos discours et je
pensais aussi grâce à eux grâce à leur
critique qui m'ont fait ce genre de
formation que j'ai pu améliorer mon
discours donc la recherche est une
grande famille tout se passe bien et
tout le monde est très content de votre
victoire c'est avez-vous soutien pour la
prochaine étape justement avant cette
prochaine étape et puis même après
comment ça va se passer pour la suite de
votre recherche de votre parcours
aujourd'hui vous nous disiez vous en
êtes à peu près la moitié de ces cinq
ans et demi donc il me reste un an et
demi pour finir ma thèse et clôturer mon
sujet et après le devenir de tout est
art s'est trouvé un poste un peu un
poste de post-doctorants en vue de
présenter les concours pour être chargé
de recherche on est des conférences et
ça il ya des ouvertures des possibilités
ne serait ce qu'en france on parlait de
la proche de la recherche de la science
par l'apa par la france est ce que la
passe en france où est-ce que c'est
plutôt vers l'étranger qu'il faut
s'orienter non il ya de la place un
france après c'est vrai que on n'a pas
les mêmes moyens que les états unis ou
que d'autres pays pour qui la recherche
est gérée de manière différente mais il
ya également mais pas cette ambition
c'est de rester sur la france où le
faire comme beaucoup de chercheurs et de
partir à l'étranger si même si beaucoup
de chercheurs partent à l'étranger je
pensais tout le temps que pour quelques
années pour un post doctorat de 2 3 1 et
je pense la plupart reviennent en france
après il ya pour s'établir merci laura
allen si na finaliste donc de ce
concours ma thèse en 180 seconde
finaliste national ce sera à nancy le 3
juin et nous vous donnerons bien sûr le
résultat merci d'être passé sur ce
plateau culture à présent et pour les
amateurs de chevaux le haras des
bréviaires vient de dévoiler son tout
nouveau spectacle 2015 qui mêle comme
toujours émotions et voltige 4 nuls à
taux zéro thorez et pour l'egypte les
images patrick jacques de dixmude
il tourne vire en toute confiance avec
l'animal morgan buvette enseignants
d'équitation et voltigeurs une pratique
tout le met en action le temps d'un
spectacle de proposer en ce moment au
haras des bréviaires un spectacle qui a
demandé plus de trois mois de
préparation
ça fait six ans que je pratique la
voltige je suis cavaliers depuis plus de
15 ans et ça fait six ans que je
pratique la musique
il ya de l'adrénaline que je trouvais
tout dans les disciplines classiques
l'équitation même si j'ai plaisir à
l'enseigné j'ai plaisir à l'ats pascal
auberson est du coup je me suis dirigé
improbable spectacle la voltige cosaque
ça mais la vitesse les prouesses
acrobatiques donc c'est là où j'ai
trouvé
je suis sur mon cheval et je descends je
remonte je suis accroché par un pied par
un bras voilà c'est ça lancés au galop
et du coup ça c'est assez spectaculaire
et
une heure et demie de spectacle avec des
voltiges de prouesses des numéros
comiques associons aussi bien le poney
que le cheval de trait les visiteurs
peuvent également découvrir le haras
national à travers des ateliers
pédagogiques prochaine séance le 29
avril à 14 heures
culture toujours de plaisir à new york
c'est le parcours que va réaliser dans
quelques jours laurent moreau un
photographe plaisir roi sélectionnés
pour participer à une exposition
collective à l'agora galerie de new york
l'exposition démarre le 24 avril
prochain et parmi elles les artistes
présents quatre français donc laurent
moreau que mathilde eu qu'à berne a
rencontré ce mercredi juste avant son
départ
j'expose à l'agora galerie de new york
qui est une des cinq plus grosses
galeries recensés par sybille est à
manhattan donc c'est la galerie qui m'a
contacté qui m'a demandé de d'exposer
chez eux pour une grande qu'à une grande
exposition qui s'appelle illuminations
c'est une ville que j'aime beaucoup et
qui contraste ou pas mal avec les voeux
les autres voyage que je fais où je suis
plutôt en immersion auprès de peuple n'a
je reviens du laos où j'ai vécu avec les
minorités ethniques du nord ouest du
laos à la frontière birmane pendant un
bon moment alors la photographie m'a
toujours j'en fais depuis que je suis
tout petit mais que j'ai décidé vraiment
d'en faire professionnellement c'est
beaucoup plus récent et puis le c'est
aussi pour moi une façon d'être militant
parce que il ya un vrai patrimoine
culturel qui est en train de de
s'évanouir complètement aussi bien
linguistique dans les costumes
traditionnels que dans les médecines
traditionnelles que voilà et
voilà j'avais envie de m'investir dans
ce dans ce créneau et puis toujours en
culture cette initiative du château de
versailles et du château de
vaux-le-vicomte qui s'associent afin de
concevoir une exposition virtuelle
inédite un nouveau regard sur deux
hommes de pouvoir louis xiv et nicolas
fouquet à découvrir en ligne et grâce à
l'institut culturel de google
environnement à présent et la réserve
naturelle de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines qui comme chaque
mois vient d'ouvrir ses portes au public
des visites guidées pour découvrir la
faune et la flore d'un site classé
natura 2000 pour la rareté et la
fragilité des espèces présentes un
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et
nicole du pain a deux passions dans sa
vie les oiseaux et la nature elle s'est
levé à l'aube ce samedi pour visiter la
réserve naturelle nationale de saint
quentin en yvelines dès 8h30
on est passionné n'était aux passionnés
donc et à son n'entend pas grand choix
enfin et c'est peut-être un peu froid
peut-être les oiseaux sont un peu
engourdie encore une visite
exceptionnelle en temps normal la
réserve naturelle n'est pas en accès
libre contrairement au reste de l'île de
loisirs le domaine accueille le public
une seule fois par mois pour profiter
pleinement de ce rendez-vous nicole du
pain senti ses jumelles et sa longue vue
pour observer les oiseaux il a offert
aux emails voyez comme ça et puis
quelque chose
ouverte depuis
1986 la réserve naturelle accueille 500
visiteurs par an à ce jour plus de 300
espèces d'oiseaux sont répertoriées sur
le site
c'est un bon spot ornithos et il faut
être bien équipé parce que les oiseaux
sont pas toujours tout près donc faut
avoir de longues focales quand on fait
de la photo ou des longues vues
d'observation comme les addictologues et
ça il ya des belles observations à faire
avec des espèces parfois très rares
ce sont des espèces sauvages les espèces
qui appartiennent à la faune et à la
flore et la réserve naturelle de saint
quentin en yvelines est surtout connue
pour sa richesse ornithologique
donc vous êtes sûrs en venant ici à 50
ans de voir facilement des oiseaux c'est
très bien pour les débutants et aussi
c'est très bien pour les initiés puisque
les observatoires vous emmène tout près
de l'étang et donc vous permet de voir
les oiseaux la réserve naturelle
nationale de saint quentin en yvelines
ouvrira à nouveau ses portes le 24 mai
pour célébrer à la fête de la nature
un reportage de nickel et demi d'euros
donc et pour terminer cette édition une
image celle de ses enfants invités par
le secours populaire ce sont plus de 150
carré minibus partie des huit
départements franciliens qui se sont
retrouvés hier au parc astérix soit 550
petit yvelinois en 2015 en ile de france
plus deux cent quarante trois mille
personnes sont aidées par le secours
populaire parmi elles 50 2000 sont des
enfants de moins de 14 ans prochain
journal à demain aux mêmes horaires tout
de suite sur ted et fils kiosque
présenté préparé par katerine the late
aux hebdomadaires de la culture très
bonne soirée